Britney rener who is I guess okay look
and I don't know who this person is all
right she's a obviously a a beautiful
woman but there's whatever I whatever I
see of her I see her I've probably seen
her no relation to Jeremy Runner by the
way I've seen her probably
online nine times in my life right and
every time I see her scrolling or
whatever it
is uh I'm like it I don't know what
brand she's going for and I I don't I'm
about to get in trouble saying this
doesn't matter I don't care but it's
always something uh like I'm like is is
it a is this a hoe thing is it a hoe
what's happening is this ho life going
on because it's f look it's fine to be a
hoe
ladies own it and then when you own it
it kind of takes a stink out of it it's
like who cares it's like whatever the
Amber rose with the [__] shame don't
it's like she's just like don't [__]
shame it's like okay so you're just a
[__] and it's all good it doesn't matter
who cares right it's like Eminem at the
end of eight mile you know yeah I suck a
lot of dicks I got a lot of dudes
[__] I had a lot of dudes in me yeah
dude's laid me down horizontally now
what are you going to say and it's like
all I was I was going to say you're a
hoe and a [__] but you kind of did
[Music]
that
yeah they on my back and take a bunch of
dudes in
me splurt it all on my man splurt it all
on my mant
section you
know so many dudes eating dudes [__]
like a hot dog you know what I'm saying
and just then it's like okay well I mean
he's said he was he's a I was going to
say he's a hoe
but so here's Britney rener says that
she doesn't regret sleeping it's always
a picture of her like popping her ass
out and then and then a some quote like
this and here's this one Britney rer say
she doesn't regret sleeping with any of
the 35 men she slept with okay so first
of all a woman who's slept with 35 men
who [__] cares like genuinely that's
not a lot I know that people are like yo
you got these soft dudes that are like
yo my chick she needs to be with a dude
that's only like been like four Dudes
and it's like yo guy first of of all
she's lying to you anyway okay second of
all who cares third of all don't tell
me do you know when Kristen told me how
many dudes she been with I go like this
yo yo yo yo I don't need to know that's
for you I don't want to know I didn't
know until one day she told me and I got
pissed not that how many but because she
told me and I I didn't want to know I
don't need need to
know and then later on she goes remember
how I said that I go yeah I didn't like
it and she said what it's actually this
many and I go you twice I'm mad
now I told you not to tell me you you
did a l twice once and then the but
anyway who cares dude
who
cares it'd be weird to be with somebody
who's only been with one or two people
talk about insecurity you'd be like are
they did they think I want a chick
that's been with 30 35 is fine to me I
don't care I me that's kind of on the
high side but also she's lying because
if you say you've had sex with 35 men
you've had sex with 45 men you know but
here's the thing I'm not this is what
you said I'm not sorry for a
[__] thing I did I don't regret
anyone I sucked [__] or swallowed I
don't have to do all that and I'm still
going to get everything I
want
deeper
um dad died early
um dude the end of that quote should be
honestly this is what that quote should
be I'm not sorry for a [__]
thing I did I don't regret anyone I
sucked [__] and swallowed I don't have
to do anything like that and I'm still
going to get everything I want my dad
died at
7 I watched my dad get hit by a train
you know what I mean like you don't even
have to they left that part out because
you understand that that's the last
part um
also here's the thing I want to know
with this ho [__] and I'm not saying
she's a hoe I always thought hoes don't
know their hoes you know what I'm saying
like if you're like yo I had sex with a
100 dudes and I did that and you're
saying it on a microphone you're not a
hoe you're a hoe If You're Li you lie
about it and you're like yeah it's been
10 dudes but there's secretly a 100
dudes out there like I got it in
there so what I want to know is who the
[__] is interviewing her about this
where is this quote
from is it [__] who bro what a weak
ass dude that has a problem with a chick
sleeping with 35
men and I mean that by the way you know
people will be like he's saying that I I
just I mean it who cares then again then
again I've got an intimacy
problem what have we learned this
episode I have an intimacy problem and I
didn't even know about that until the
last three
years I was
40 I had been living 40 years with an
intimacy problem and didn't know about
it I make fun of guys who don't know
they're gay until they're older but I
have got no right to do that because I
didn't know I
had an intimacy problem for 40
years I thought [__] was all gravy I
thought I was totally emotional
intelligent because I cried
sometimes
[Music]
no I'm walled
up was